the quality of your life has nothing to
do with how much money you have on any
beautiful children you have how many
people love you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally this is the time to
retool it's a time for you to say
where's the world now where do i think
it's going and what am i going to do to
add value
just for everybody listening take a
quick test with me
believe nation welcome back i've got a
very special guest a personal mentor of
mine for a number of years
somebody who's been called the world's
number one life and business
strategist and the last time we
connected we nearly broke the internet
and had almost two
million views on our interview the one
and only
mr tony robbins welcome back thanks evan
great to be with you
i didn't know you had two million views
that's pretty awesome congratulations
well that was our interview together
that was crazy the one we did talking
about your book
a couple years ago yeah two million
views which for thought leadership
interview content is crazy most people
don't spend that much time watching
those interviews so it was amazing and
we're doing it again round two here we
go i'm excited
well it seems like the right time with
governor people trapped in their homes
my goodness
people really we all need to figure out
how to recraft our lives right now
yeah i mean i just finished your your
date with destiny program was amazing oh
that's awesome i didn't know you were
there that's great
life-changing so many breakthroughs i
did it with my wife and um
i'm excited about the new program that
you're launching
new world new you yes quickly just
before that
talk to me about new year's resolutions
why do people
seem to be so bad at following through
on their new year's resolutions
i think as most people call it a
resolution and all it really is is
expressing a desire it's more like a
little habit well it's a new year and
the new year gives us
this beautiful opportunity it's totally
illusionary it's in our head it's a new
year is a new start it's a new way of
being right
and in this year it's new year it's a
new world but i think the reason people
don't really do it is they don't
actually resolve
a resolution is to resolve something you
resolve something it means you cut off
any possibility except what you've
committed to it's kind of like
when i say you know if you want to take
the island burn your boats because as
long as your mind has a way out when
things get tough
you'll rationalize and you'll back off
and so the other reason i think is that
you know i think it's 85 percent of
people have broken the resolution by the
first week of february it might be even
higher these days
and i heard this year very few people
are making resolutions because they feel
out of control in their life
but the thing you need to make sure is a
resolution something you resolve it's
this important you have such strong
reasons but also you need rituals to
make it real
if your resolution is i'm going to lose
30 pounds and the first thing you do
every morning is go to starbucks and
have a mocha smoke or whatever you know
obviously that habit is not going to get
you where you want to go
and so what i always do is make sure if
you've got a resolution then you've got
to have some rituals they're going to
back it up those habits
they're going to make it turn to
something real and most important it's
got to have strong enough reasons
because
if it was easy to make a resolution
happen everybody be living the
resolutions but it's not
you're going to bump into challenges and
what will keep you going is having a
strong enough purpose strong enough
reason that says this is why i'm doing
this
if you don't have that you're not going
to follow through and you're unlikely to
get any real results
so you've got your new challenge new
world new you challenge five day
challenge
for free that people can sign up for
we're gonna put the link down in the
description below you can go check it
out
tell us why you're doing this and what
people can expect
well last july i just everybody's stuck
at home and i've just felt for so many
people i mean
you know i'm driven after work another
day in my life fortunately but i work
harder than ever and it's like i'm
driven to see
people get out of suffering and get back
into joy and back in control of their
life and
i was thinking i got to do something for
people and so we combined uh
eric over at zoom is a good friend of
mine i got him to expand the size of
zoom the biggest they've ever done
and we had just under 400 000 people
that participated with us
for this challenge and it's supposed to
be an hour a day but i get a little
carried away so if you come join me
it'll probably be an hour and a half or
two
because i just want to add as much value
as possible we took every area of a
person's life
their body their emotions their
relationships their finances their
career or their business
and showed them here are some cool
strategies and tools you can use right
now and we workshopped it
and um it was just amazing because then
we put people in facebook group and
they're still there from six months ago
so everybody's saying please it's it's a
new year it's it's a new world and i
thought that's a really good way of
describing it it really is a new world
and you
you can't do the same things you're
doing before and expect it's going to
work out
so i'm doing five days starting on
january 21st
at 2 p.m eastern but we'll have people
from more than 100 countries
we already have uh about 450 000 people
i've already signed up so
i think we'll end up with about three
quarters of a million people and for one
week we're just going to train people to
see what they can do to take control of
their life in each of those areas that
matter to the most
and again there's no charge for it my my
payback
is we give people a challenge each day
to grow and they get great results and
they share that story and of course
that helps me reach more people too the
website talks about helping people
craft a new world plan for themselves
yes what does that mean to you well you
before you can craft the new world plan
you got to understand the world you're
in and how it's changed right
and the second part though is you got to
know your your life is controlled more
by your decisions
than it is conditions we've all been
through rough conditions these are
pretty rough ones
you know it's seasonal meaning you know
every 20 years we have a
change in the attitude the mindset of
people and there's actually a beautiful
book it's it's not well
written but it is brilliant to read as
that sounds contradictory but
it's called the fourth turning and it's
been a book that i've come back to over
the last 20 years and it shows how
history moves in cycles
and if you understand how the world is
changing you can start to anticipate
what you're going to build
what i tell people you first have to do
is take control the three decisions that
control
your life because right now whatever
you're experiencing you could be locked
up in your house and nowhere to go and
have total joy you could be locked into
your house and angry you could be locked
in your house and be depressed
right or you could not be locked in your
house and find a way to go do work
anyway legally in a way that isn't quite
problems
there's so many options of what we can
do but the problem is
three decisions control us and your
listeners and watch and viewers right
now
can test it within themselves the three
decisions we make we don't usually make
them consciously
i mean they're more like um unconscious
for most people which is why the results
they get are so poor but the first
question is
decision you got to make is what am i
going to focus on so right now there are
millions of things you can focus on you
can focus on the past the present the
future what's going on in your body
they're touching your clothes against
your skin against your body there's a
million things you can focus on but our
brain
can only handle about you know somewhere
between three and seven at a time
it's our capacity to consciously
organize and chunk
and so whatever you focus on you feel so
if you
you know if you're saying oh my god the
world's over we're never going to be
able back to normal again we're never
going to have a relationship with
another human we're going to avoid each
other at all costs
well if you picture that you imagine it
you're going to feel it as if it's real
if you think somebody has screwed you
over you're going to be angry even if
it's not true i don't know how many of
your viewers
have ever done this but you got really
mad someone told you something and you
got mad because you felt hurt
and you confront this person and it
never even happened
right it's just what happens in our
heads we feel what we focus on and most
of us don't control our focus
so just for everybody listening take a
quick test with me i'll give you three
ways you focus
and let's see their impact there are
dozens but just take these three
number one do you tend to focus all of
your listening
on what you can control or what you
can't control
now in a covet environment it's easy to
focus on what you can't control but i'm
just saying generally we all focus on
both
where do you spend more of your time if
you're focusing on what you can't
control and there's plenty we can't
control
you're going to be angry or sad or
frustrated overwhelmed or stressed
if you focus on what you can control
you're start to make some form of
progress but as long as your head goes
oh my god we're out of control nothing
can happen
that level of focus will take you take
no action and you'll just experience
more of what your self-fulfilling
prophecy another question
did you tend to focus more on what you
have or what's missing
now i ask these questions when i'm you
know previous to covid
last march my average seminar is 15 000
people so i got a stadium full of people
big ones 30
000 people and when i asked them this
most of the people coming to my seminars
are overachievers
and about 80 of them focus on what's
missing
and there's nothing wrong with that if
it gets you to take action and do
something but when you're constantly
focusing on what's missing it doesn't
matter what you achieve i call it the
achiever's curse
you're it's never enough and there's
always an emptiness inside
you can't build on failure so people who
take on a pattern of focusing on what
they can control
and focusing secondly on what they do
have and the grace of that
their psychology is completely different
i'll give you one more do you tend to
focus on the past more
the present or the future now again in
covet a lot of people
they're looking at looking at the future
through the present right
or hoping for what was in the past but
if you focus on the past you can't
control it you focus in the present you
can enjoy what's going on if you use
your mind properly
if you focus in the future you can
anticipate so watch
evan i ask people this all the time i
say how many of you know somebody
who takes who's depressed they take
antidepressants and they're still
depressed and in a big audience thirty
thousand fifteen thousand people ten
thousand people
ninety percent of people know somebody
who takes antipresence they're still
depressed
why well all the antidepressant does is
numb you
right so the hope you can deal with
stuff more but you don't
because the person is depressed i
guarantee you you ask them questions
you'll discover they're focused on
what's missing
constantly they're focused on what they
can't control and they tend to focus on
the past
it doesn't matter what drug we give you
the source of your pain
are those three decisions and once you
decide what you're going to focus on
again most people don't do it
consciously
and most people are focusing what they
don't have second decision got to decide
is what does this mean
like what does it mean right now does
this mean the world as we know it is
over
is this god punishing us is are you just
a lazy bastard and you're just giving up
too easily
see whatever meaning you give it is
someone disrespecting me are they
challenging me are they loving me are
they coaching me
one meaning change and that instantly
changes the emotion you have
and listen the quality of your life has
nothing to do with how much money you
have on any beautiful children you have
how many people love you
the quality of your life is where you
live emotionally if you got a billion
dollars
and every single day of your life all
you're focused on is what you're worried
about your life is worry or what you're
angry about your life is anger
so we have to take control of what we
focus on we got to come up with new
meanings empowering meetings and then
that affects what your
final decision is what am i going to do
so in our
challenge each day we're going to give
people some tools
and we're going to give them a chance to
go try those tools overnight
interact with everybody in the facebook
group from more than 100 countries
and then come back and go to step 2. so
we're going to help them kind of build a
plan
to see what's controlling them and think
of this way oven everything in the world
is controlled by two worlds the outside
world the inside world well we can't
control all the outside world we can
influence it
but we can completely control goes on
the inside world and by doing that you
take control of your life regardless of
covid regardless of political unrest etc
when i went to my first upw i remember
there was a woman who was
maybe 20 rows ahead of me who would
always get up and just
feel free you know the music came on and
she would just kind of let loose and
just live out loud
uh and i felt kind of restricted and
kind of like man i wish i could be
i could live my life out loud like her
yeah and then i went to the website for
the new world new you challenge and
one of the things on there is you say
you teach people how they can live their
new life
out loud i'm like oh my god he's putting
them into this workshop is amazing
what does that mean to live out loud and
and then how are you
bringing that to the the new world new
challenge well
living out loud to me is living your
true self it's not shrinking it's not
letting the environment shut you down i
mean you know some people just
have this hunger to grow to expand to
find a better way
to not settle for less they can be or do
or shape or create other people
they don't know that's even possible it
has to get triggered for them but the
way we did it is like you know i'm used
to
doing these giant events and all of a
sudden you can imagine suddenly the
government's all around the world
in amsterdam and russia in you know uk
all over the us shut everything down and
it's like
this is my mission this isn't just like
business for me so i was like how do i
make this work and at first i thought
i'm gonna go to
you know a movie theaters oh they they
shrunk the number of people you can't do
10 000 people
okay we'll do a thousand movie theaters
you know with you know 50 100 200 people
in each type of thing
and then they shut down the movie
theaters then it was like oh we're going
to do this in churches they shut down
the churches and the one thing i said
i'd never do
to get people in that state you're
talking about is they can't do it in
their homes
because you know i'm in a stadium and we
got a rock star music and we got you
know the group
dynamic but the living out loud was
showing people how to do it in their
homes it's
wild again i said i would never do it
and i'm like okay i'm not going to do
some
old man's webinar how do we do this and
so i hired seven companies and we built
this zoom stadium
i went to eric young and said i want to
be able to work with 30 000 people at a
time they were only doing a thousand got
him to work with it
and then what we created is these 50
foot high ceilings
uh you know 50 foot wide led you know
retina screens so i can see
three thousand people at a time swipe
seeing another three thousand all
surrounded around me we can bring them
up
so the ability to be able to interact
and coach people
is virtually the same as there but what
triggered me to tell you this is
a lot of people like yourself will see
some people are more free and what i
found
is that people are loving this because
there's nobody else there they're part
of a community because you're part of
the dynamic as it's happening the music
and the energy and what we're doing
but they're in their home so no one else
is looking at them you know their dog
might be
you know husband or wife might be and
what's been really beautiful to see
is people waking up living out loud
living what they believe in their own
home with their own family you know
people come to an event before
fly to the other part of the country fly
another another country when i go over
overseas and be away for four or five
days and come back and try to explain
what they experience
now i'm watching their children jump in
during these you know blessing
experiences they're setting their goals
and
it's been really really beautiful to see
so our whole focus is
for those who haven't come to a live
event we want to provide them five days
live no charge for them if they want to
then do business with us
great but if they don't at least we've
helped them to put together the initial
plan to start living life on their
standards regarding the outside
regardless of the outside world
i've been a bunch here in person and
then we did the virtual date with
destiny
and it was awesome you know i didn't
know how it would work out but we put it
we put you on our projected tv
and had the sound blasting and the music
was blasting and yeah same experience of
going
to a live event where you kind of get
there in the morning
and then all of a sudden it's eight
o'clock at night
what happened how has that transitioned
to online been for you and i know that
the new world new challenge
is not going to be that long every day
it's just an hour an hour and a half but
how has the transition online been for
you
it's been really interesting the
beginning was very tough obviously you
know it's like
you're used to doing things a certain
way i've refined it over the years you
know most people won't sit for a
three-hour movie
and i get people in a live environment
you know going 12 14 hours a day for
three or four days in a row
because i believe in total immersion
it's like you can read about swimming or
you can go swimming and if you go
swimming day and night
you master it you know that's what you
experience the day with destiny but
i went through the emotions that i think
a lot of people have gone through i hope
your
viewers are listening it's like did you
go through the stages ideas like the
stages of death when there's a huge loss
first there's shock what are you talking
about like i remember somebody called me
and said
you know are you going to cancel your
event in san francisco and like
last year i i got mercury poisoning and
i bled out i lost a third of my blood
supply
and the doc said you're here for the
next three days i sit home in the middle
of the seminar i said
he goes you can't do that i said you
can't keep me here so they gave me a
wheelchair and i finished the seminar in
a wheelchair i mean that's how
incredibly intense i am in this area and
so i was like
cancel the bed i've never canceled one
i'm never gonna cancel that and then the
government canceled it for me so i went
through
it's impossible shocked then i went
through anger which is what people do
when they have a loss like a death
and then i went through bargaining come
on god there's got to be a way to help
these people you know
and then you go through the sadness or
some people loss or depression
and then eventually hopefully people
complete that cycle by acceptance like
okay
i can't control it it's over i just got
to do my best with it
but i think there's a step beyond that
after acceptance is
creating a new that's really what this
whole experience is about this new world
to you is like
who do i need to be in this new world to
be effective how do i need to find a way
to add more value
and so that's what i got in the creation
mode because i went through all the
emotions anybody did it's like
you just shut down my life's work when
people need it most
this is impossible and you know we tried
a million different things we moved
locations and you know to vegas and they
shut down vegas and
to texas they said their numbers they
shut them down so it's like
what it made us do is pivot and i think
that's really what we're going to show
people how to do when they come to this
program is figure out where can you add
value in this new world
how can you find joy where there seem to
be restrictions
and also reminding people if this is
winter i've been talking about this to
all my clients forever financial winter
but now it's emotional winter and you
know there's a health winter here
it's all happening at once but winter is
not forever i know when things are going
great people think it's going to go
great forever it's why they get killed
in the stock market because they don't
pay attention
or when things are going terrible people
think it's going to go terrible forever
it's just not true
you know it's tough it's rough how long
is this going to last
longer than we want but will last
forever hell no one on the other side
will be springtime it's like what
follows the night
the day if you were god when you put it
together that way that's pretty cool
but we got to do our part in the
meantime and i figured if i can help
people all over the world at no charge
for five days and nights i think we can
make a significant difference for
maybe three quarters of a million people
maybe a million people might join us
i love it well and i think one of the
things you're great at is building
community
and bringing people together so as much
as
as tony robbins is the main you also get
to meet other
amazing people i mean that's the best
part of it to me because especially now
because
you've helped friends all over the world
and you have a personal
connection to them now you know in a
seminar you meet them you develop
personal connection and you go home
but because of the way we live digitally
today these people can stay your friends
and they do and it's it's really
beautiful seeing
i did this in july for the first time
and i said i was gonna do one this year
and everybody wrote to me he said do it
the front of the year do it right here
at the beginning so we get a new start
so that's why we're doing it but it's
been nice of these last six months to
see all these relationships created with
people
supporting each other networking giving
them different tools and strategies and
so it's not just me of course
it's really about as you said creating a
community of people that can support and
help you
and if you don't do it you're gonna be
isolated right you know and so most
people
are dealing with the same people and
knowing with the same thinking and the
same approach and so you get the same
result which is not very exciting right
now
but if you want something new my
original teacher was a guy named jim
rohn and he used to say
great ideas have to be pursued they're
not going to stop and interrupt you and
go here i am to help you
and so this is a time if you're stuck at
home or not
this is the time to retool it's a time
for you to say where's the world now
where do i think it's going and what am
i going to do to add value
because to me probably the greatest
insight i ever got was from my teacher
jim rohn i remember
i went to him and i had you know
forefathers and we were always broke and
you know i i literally had a
thanksgiving with no food which is why i
provide 100 million meals a year through
feeding america every year i've been
doing it i said i'd feed a billion
people i started
six and a half years ago and we're at
700 million meals so we're gonna have a
billion meals for people that need it
but it's not because i'm so good it's
because i went through those times when
i didn't have
anything we didn't have the food i
remember asking jim rohn like why are my
fathers all broke why don't we have
enough food
and he said you know you got to
understand everybody is equal
spiritually emotionally as souls but
we're not equal in the marketplace
and he said your fathers are good men
but they did not learn how to become
more valuable
he said tony if you work at mcdonald's
there's nothing wrong with mcdonald's
but if you work at mcdonald's you're
going to get minimum wage because
anybody can learn those skills
these days in a few minutes because you
don't even have to know the language
they got images to hit
the buttons he said but you know you see
these guys that are let's say a hedge
fund guy who made a billion dollars last
year
and you go that's so unfair he goes tony
you're not understanding
that guy got a return of 34 in a
marketplace where most people got one
percent so he's created jobs
opportunities schools
kids having graduate i mean everything
you can imagine so
he's worth a billion because he
generated
hundreds of billions of dollars for
other people he said so
what you got to realize is your focus in
life has to be how do you add more value
than anybody else in the marketplace and
to do that you got to keep growing
you got to keep adding to your skills
and that's really what we're going to do
with people this week is help them
figure out what is that niche for them
so they can create their own economy and
they can enjoy themselves and they can
have the vitality and health and
relationships they want
regardless of whether they're stuck in
their house for a period of time or not
i love it well it's the new world new
you
challenge the link to join is in the
description get on there
five days absolutely free with tony
robbins
and his friends if you've never been to
a live training i've been to
six i think over the years it's very
amazing so if you haven't experienced it
yet this is your chance to get in for
free go check out the link
tony thanks for the love as always man
appreciate you thank you buddy make 2020
your best year but everybody let's not
settle
we got to take this situation and turn
into something good blessings to you
if you want to see the last one-on-one
interview i did with tony robbins that
got almost 2
million views check out the video right
there next to me i think you'll enjoy it
continue to believe and i'll see you
there tony welcome aboard man
thanks evan great to be with you